hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from the
UK the USA and around the world with
just days until Iowa is this Republican
candidate unstoppable and just ahead of
the final TV debate or even bother to
show up to mail and to whites is a
little change a little too late for
Hollywood host Chris Rock is rewriting
his opening monologue we wonder what
should he say
first to the race for the White House
and they're running neck-and-neck now
even Ted Cruz says Donald Trump could be
unstoppable
if he wins next week's Iowa caucus as we
record this show on Wednesday we are 24
hours or so away from the last TV debate
before Iowa makes its decision and as we
speak an unresolved spat between Fox
News and Donald Trump could mean that
mr. Trump does a no-show well as usual
Democrat commentator Jeffrey Robinson is
standing by in New York conservative
commentator Armstrong Williams is in
Washington let me at her Armstrong first
on this occasion should he show up on
strim it is a colossal mistake one of
the most important things about running
for president is your temperament and
mr. Trump should in spite of the fact he
may have issues with megyn kelly he is
bigger than all of this he's leading the
polls I mean what is going on in his
mind and in mind of his advisors to make
him believe that he's the front-runner
dominating and he doesn't need to show
up for this presidential debate Fox
would make a parody of him with if the
cher chair he will be the casualty at
all and are we in the media are gonna
give in to candidates just because they
don't like anchors they demand they they
don't participate and we're gonna count
either that there's no way we can
embrace that kind of president Jeffrey
what do you think what should Fox News
do should they change the anchor person
no not at all from a journalistic
standpoint Armstrong is right from ever
the other standpoint he's dead wrong
this is not a colossal mistake it's a
cause of gamble and a gamble that is
calculated Roger Ailes
has released or at least in his name was
has released a couple of tweets and and
press releases that have basically
ridiculed Trump and Trump is not going
to do what the other Republicans always
do which is kowtow to Fox News Now
journalistically know he should not be
allowed to chip to select his his
questioners but from this standpoint
there will not be an empty chair they
will simply not be a place for him I
mean the podium will not be it will not
be an empty podium on the stage there
will be seven
that's all the fact is that he will not
show up he's got a whole an alternative
event now if that event for the wounded
warriors and disabled veterans is big
enough he will get coverage from all of
the other networks and you'll see if the
viewership drops as I suspect it will
substantially because nobody cares about
those other seven people Trump is the
start if he doesn't show up they're not
gonna watch the debate they will watch
him instead on the alternative channels
if that happens his gamble will have
paid off big time and I think he knows
what he's doing well let's bring in Kate
Andrews who's a research fellow at Adam
Smith Institute a colonist at London's
first free city newspaper that's City AM
and a fully paid-up of member of
Republicans oversees fully paid-up in
the sense it's free to join I know that
Kate what do you make of this Donald
Trump show no show issue do you think he
should go to the debate well I think it
just feeds into the personality that
he's already showing to the world which
is that this election is about him it's
about him getting more attention he was
a huge star and the only way to become a
bigger stars to run for president of the
United States this has nothing to do
about communicating the issues he has to
the people has nothing to do about
representing people's issues on a
national platform it has to do with him
and his pride and the attention that he
gets and the fact that he is boycotting
Fox News for putting megyn kelly back up
on that platform a world-renowned
journalist who has proven herself time
and time again to be fair and competent
fact that he's boycotting her because
she brought up months ago some things
that he has factually said in the past
about women is not helping the persona
that he's already other other people
already believe him to have about his
relationship with women and minorities
and yet Kay some of the polling they did
after that whole spat and the thing he
said the next day about megyn kelly
insinuating either directly or
indirectly that she was menstruating at
the time of the debate and this was some
reason why she was so horrible to him
did that really damage Donald Trump in
the eyes of Women Voters here's the
thing we don't know yet we don't know if
his comments about women and megyn kelly
specifically his comments about
immigration is comments about Mexicans
we have no idea if this has hurt him yet
we will find out on Monday the polls
have put him ahead of senator Ted Cruz
again back in Iowa the polls on the
whole are suggesting that Donald Trump
is going to win in Iowa if those polls
turn out to be correct then it very well
may be the case that this angry rhetoric
is working with a large amount of people
who want to show up to vote but if it's
the case and I suspect there's a
potential for this that we come we come
away from Monday realizing that the kind
of people who say they're going to vote
for Trump are not the likely voters who
do show up and vote for Trump then he is
in real trouble just bring in Jeffrey
and Armstrong back into the conversation
now Jeffrey just remind us of the
folklore around Iowa it sort of goes
first and everybody puts an awful lot of
storr by it but does it really matter
that much no it actually doesn't except
in this case I mean look at who the
Republican which Republicans won Iowa in
the past you know Rick Santorum who why
bother
it doesn't mean anything except in the
case of Trump and Cruz if Trump beats
Cruz and I expect he will because this
stand against megyn kelly and Fox is
exactly what his electorate wants him to
do he's standing up to bullies and they
like that if he wins in Iowa he will win
in New Hampshire a win in South Carolina
and Kate and and Armstrong and all their
Republican establishment friends are
gonna sit there shaking their head
wondering how they let this get away
from him because if he wins those three
it's basically over
he's already ahead in the polls in
Florida beating Jeb Bush and Marco Rubio
combined together they will lose too
they will lose to him this is a runaway
train and there's very little they can
do to stop and except hope that somehow
Ted Cruz who by the way is ineligible to
be president wins in Iowa what I just
was that just asserted that Ted Cruz is
ineligible to be President
oh my goodness oh goodness this was
ridiculous and I was no Barack Obama
supporter but this was ridiculous in
2008 and it's ridiculous now the law is
clear about this he is an American
citizen and he was at birth I'd also
like to point out that the establishment
is not exactly my friend and I don't
think that this is exact
a runaway train the establishment has
been attacking Ted Cruz more than it's
been attacking Donald Trump probably
because they're worried that people like
Ted Cruz and Rand Paul might change the
establishment in a way that is not
changing we can't change it back and I
think it's gonna be clear where some of
those pitfalls were I will certainly be
worried if Donald Trump ends up being a
winner in these three states but I don't
think the establishment and I will be on
exactly the same page let me bring it up
from here can Ted Cruz stand can he be
President Ted Cruz put so much of his
resources had the best ground game and
Iowa and when mr. Trump began to
challenge him on what is the ridiculous
whether he's a American citizen or not
it's pretty outrageous it's so sad that
it began to stick with the press and
that narrative began to spread you know
listen Ted Cruz doesn't have many
friends in the United States Senate Ted
Cruz is being undermined by many people
that he has played roughshod over in
that body where there's the quorum
there's respect and you don't use
nuclear taxes and so much of what has
happened in him even with the governor
Branson and I who came out in a clear
assault on him and others it has to do
with the fact that they just don't like
him they don't like his combative
personality but I do think that I guess
makes a very good point this is not
about the establishment look I think
that this just truck not showing up and
I'm not sure he's gonna follow through
with it I hope he comes to his good
senses he is not above the debates he's
not above the fact that he hasn't shown
that even in the end what they used in
the papers if he were in a meeting with
Putin you just don't walk up because you
don't get your way you got to go in and
face these people head-on and to Jeffers
point where he's totally wrong over 60%
of his supporters say that Trump should
show up tomorrow night at the debate
it's just a colossal mistake it plays
into the into the hands of the fact that
he thinks he's too good for Heba made
the comment last week which was
outrageous if people saw him shooting
people live they would still vote for
him it plays into his ego and isn't
arrogance to believe that he can do in
and
everything he wants to do and the people
will not leave him and I think he's
sadly mistaken
Geoffrey just explained to us just wind
back a second on why you think Ted Cruz
on to an American citizen and his mother
right he's not eligible to be a
president it's not what I think it's
with a number of constitutional experts
including Larry tribe Cruz's the
constitutional law professor Harvard
thing and what people in Illinois think
who are going to deny him to be on the
ballot because he is not eligible
citizenship at Birth for a non-resident
citizen if you're born overseas the way
Cruz was born in Canada citizenship is
bequeathed by a request from a US
citizen parent I know this firsthand
because both of my children were born in
France within 12 hours of their birth
they had US passports and a super
certificate that said a certificate of
an American born overseas they are
entitled to citizenship through me you
have to ask for it it is always granted
but that's not what the Constitution
says Armstrong is dead wrong about you
can run if you're a citizen the
Constitution says natural-born American
yeah Cruz was born in Canada doesn't
matter who his mother was doesn't matter
who his father was although he might
also have had Cuban citizenship it
matters where he was born and under
Canadian law and US law which recognizes
Canadian law he is a natural-born
Canadian and that's in the Constitution
so a young front cake really needs to
get educated on this because it is not
ridiculous the point is the Constitution
says natural-born American because in
the 18th century there was a debate in
England about natural born British and
the British Parliament ruled that if you
are the child of a British subject born
overseas you will be considered a
natural-born Briton the American
Founding Fathers the American Founding
Fathers specifically rejected that they
didn't say the American president has to
be a citizen they said he has to be a
natural-born American Ted Cruz is a
natural-born Canadians well let me give
Kate some come back this is some of the
best news I've had in a while because
the whole time I was thinking that
Donald Trump supporters were on such a
high and they thought they were so close
to victory they
just gonna sweep up all of the primaries
and move on but back in 2008 John when
John McCain supporters were getting
pretty desperate they brought out all
this birthright citizen nonsense they
were accusing Barack Obama of not having
an American birth certificate they were
accusing him of all these different
things and they were desperate and I'm
really pleased to hear that Donald Trump
supporters are actually not doing as
well as I suspected because for you to
be accusing senator Ted Cruz one of the
most conservative candidates on the
stage for not being a naturally born
American citizen and he is a naturalized
American citizen yes he is he was born
to an American mother in Canada he is
immediately granted American citizenship
he's immediately granted American
citizenship this issue and I am so
pleased to say that the Donald Trump
supporters are struggling so much that
they are bringing out these kinds of
arguments okay
listen to yourself this is nonsense we
know the constitutional experts are
gonna go over and over this and I don't
think we're gonna solve it in the next
two or three minutes but can I can I
please do one other question which is
that Michael Bloomberg Jeffery what's up
judge it has nothing to do with
citizenship the words in the
Constitution are natural-born American
John McCain was a natural-born American
having been born in the Panama Canal
Zone which was an American territory on
a u.s. naval base which is American
sovereign territory same thing with
Barry Goldwater having been born in in
Arizona Territory u.s. territory Barack
Obama was born in Hawaii but
interestingly enough what Ted Cruz said
about Barack Obama at the time is he
can't be he's not eligible to be
President because he was born of a
Moroccan of a knight Kenyan father in
Kenya which is not true that he said of
his own problem is I was born of an
American mother in Canada it's of no
significance who my father was
I mean that's utter double-talk the
Constitution is very clear natural-born
America American has nothing to do with
the fact that he's a citizen he is
everything to run the Supreme Court will
rule against the war ties he lawsuits he
will not be on the ticket enough time
out we're not gonna fix this in the next
couple of minutes of our program I don't
think but I do want to put to you one
other thought and this is the the
Lumbergh factor which emerged over the
last seven days now don't scoff too much
because I think it's it's a fascinating
prospect if there is a candidate from
the hard left if there is a candidate
such as a Trump from the extreme right
Michael Bloomberg mayor of new one-time
mayor of New York says he might run and
go right through the middle
let me ask Kate what do you think of
that idea well Bloomberg I think went
off the rails a little bit towards the
end of his time in New York
he is crackdown on sugary drinks or
things that don't really resonate with
Americans I know that debate is
happening over here in the UK but on the
whole Americans get very upset when the
government tries to interfere in the
home and interfere it certainly on the
products that they're gonna buy or feed
to their families and their kids that
being said he has a long tenure and he
has accomplished he could accomplish
much much during his time in New York
and I think another billionaire getting
involved in the raise putting his own
money behind it and it's I think it's
probably too late it's probably too much
it probably seems a little too similar
to Trump even though their views I would
say are drastically different I think
what you were more likely to see if say
Donald Trump got the nomination and and
so did Bernie Sanders but I think is
unlikely but possible he's leading
Hillary in the polls in both Iowa and
New Hampshire
I think it's possible you'd see one of
the more establishment Republicans run
as an independent not guaranteeing that
by any stretch of the imagination but I
do think you might see more people enter
into the race
I don't think Bloomberg has the backing
from either party that's the fundamental
problem is that he is in many ways an
independent and he wouldn't have the
establishment Republicans or the
establishment Democrats helping his
campaign Kate Andrews good to meet you
today thank you very much indeed
now reminder you can catch up with the
Sky News debate on Apple TV on roku and
catch up and of course at Sky News com /
us the Academy says it's going to some
lengths to make their members less male
and less white after intense criticism
over its lack of diversity in this
year's Oscar nominations Hollywood is
after all a global advertisement for the
United States so what does this
controversy say about the great nation
well Sam full-width the third is from
the Center for American Progress so he
joins us now from our Washington studio
Sam Fullwood thank you for being with us
today what do you think this Oscar spat
is it a stormy Latika for is there
something really fundamental gone wrong
here yes and no to both questions I
think that it is a storm in a teacup
in the sense that vast numbers of people
aren't paying attention to wherever the
Oscars are going on it's sort of a
closed shop but there is a really large
point to be made by what's going on with
this with this controversy as you call
it the Oscars the movie industry
Hollywood really does have a global
impact on our society and on the world
by projecting images and those images
have a way of sticking and becoming
reality for large numbers of people I
noticed this because whenever I travel
internationally the one common
denominator that I always hear is people
talking about the movies that they have
seen and the movies that come out of
Hollywood it is a way of sort of
exporting our culture and sometimes
imposing that culture on other cultures
and so the failure to be as inclusive as
possible out of Hollywood is a serious
problem and is it down to the judges who
may or may not select the widest
possible range of actors or do you think
it's one of those things that just the
movies and the roles that black actors
played this time around just didn't make
the cut well you know I think that there
there is a system that is in place that
makes
this whole thing the problem yes they're
not very many black or Hispanic or Asian
actors who are getting meaty roles but
part of that is has to do with how the
industry finances its movies who gets to
greenlight what is done what scripts are
shown to what agents are there's a whole
network that's involved in making movies
and for the most part people of color
and other minorities are not a part of
that network so that you can you can
pull on one thread of it and it
reverberates through the whole spiderweb
of Hollywood let me bring in Jeffrey and
Armstrong at this point I'm strong what
how do you take this route do you think
it's a concocted route listen I think
there are some indications about
Hollywood and I mean let's just look at
what they've signed off on in terms of
black actors and actresses winning the
Oscar you look at Monique and precious
look at Denzel Washington in training
day you look at Halle Berry and Monster
Ball really demeaning roles which would
really protest that loudly within many
circles when it was announced and yet
you see the wonderful roles they play
where they're role models and the kind
of values and virtues that they
represent they were not even closely
selected to win the Oscar for those
roles
I think Hollywood does all the right
things they march they speak out against
racism and they speak out against
bigotry they're the first to take the
Republican Party and others to test but
yet they don't deal with their own
racism their own bigotry and their own
sense of the roles that blacks should
play and what in who and what is
deserving of an Oscar so I think this is
a systemic issue I think what Sam and
others are talking about only scratches
the surface
I think liberal Hollywood whether people
are willing willing to admit it or not
is probably still one of the most racist
bastions of racism in America Jeffrey do
you read Hollywood like that no of
course not I mean I happen to be a lot
closer to the situation than Armstrong
is the film Academy is made up of
fifty-one governor's my brother is one
of them and he's also on the main board
and they have been meeting
frantically to come up with a solution
he says that will will increase
diversity I think that it's going to
double it or triple it by the year 2017
or 2020 I think it is they are very
concerned but you spoke about judges who
nominate these films that's not how it
works
and Sam will tell you that the way it
works is the 6000 members of the Academy
and get screeners from the the producers
and the studios and they vote to
nominate and then they vote on the
nominations to win so this is down not
to the Board of Governors who really
wanted to do something and you will not
find a more liberal Bunch when it comes
to gender equality of sexual proclivity
equality racial equality you won't find
51 more liberal people in the entire
country
the fact is the president of the Academy
is a black woman named Cheryl Boone
Isaacs
unfortunately I look down the list and
she may be the only black face on the
Board of Governors it's broken
Jeffrey and Sam come in on this he's
broken the membership needs to change
doesn't it no no not the membership is
made up the membership is made up of the
six thousand people in the film business
what has to change is that the studio on
production level where they lobby these
six thousand members very very hard for
political and commercial reasons that's
what needs to change the Academy will do
what it has to do but it's the six
thousand members who are being
constantly bombarded by the studios and
and the producers to nominate and that's
that system somehow has to change son I
don't think that we have a real strong
disagreement here the there is a system
in place for nominations for four Oscars
that system is skewed in such a way that
people of color minorities and others
are not a part of the system and that's
the real problem I think that the that
Hollywood as its as a it is an industry
is is it's a misnomer for being declared
liberal or conservative what they really
are are capitalist and they're looking
to maximize their investments so that
that's that
really has nothing to do with what we're
really talking about what we're really
talking about is the system that they
have in place for determining who gets
nominated and who does not get nominated
and the real-world implications for what
happens when those people do or do not
get get nominated do not get recognized
for contributing to the image making
that Hollywood produces and let me put
the point to all of you I mean if there
was some kind of quota system in place
where once you got up to some kind of
nominal nominations or hang on we
haven't got any person of color in this
list so we're gonna have to bump them up
that wouldn't then be a basis of winning
out of merit would it it would be - in
order to fill the quota unstrung you
know it all boils down to your values
your perspectives what you consider to
be entertainment what you consider to be
oscar-worthy and and many come from
different backgrounds and while you may
say this film is the best it's still a
judgment call I mean when you hear
people like Jada Pinkett and Will Smith
for husbands say that they're not gonna
attend the Oscars this year I mean
they're a part of the Hollywood
structure they produced the films and
they're part of the inner circle even
yet they cry against what is systemic
and I think so for what is exactly right
there's not a system in place where
these people can vet
minorities in these roles to the point
where they're considered for and asked
it and I still believe that they also
have in their minds what is defined as a
role for minorities and was defined is
what is oscar-worthy what a minority is
portraying and acted in that role
Jeffery know the the nominations the
primaries the first batch of films is
selected by the studios and the
producers they're the ones that say
we're going to put this up for a
nomination and not this one that's where
the problem lies the 6,000 people who
vote on it only get what the studios and
the producers send them those are the
choices they then vote and that's
narrowed down to whether it's six or
eight or eleven in some cases however
many nominations which they then vote on
the second time for a winner but the
choice of films doesn't come from the
Academy they have nothing to do with it
okay doesn't come out the members
nothing
the final vote no Sam here Chris Rock
was was asked was he to consider should
eat should he back out
as some kind of protest he's gonna stick
there and do the hosting job but
apparently he's rewriting his opening
words I wonder what he's gonna come up
with and say Sam uh you know Chris Rock
is a a brilliant comic and I would not
try to put words into his mouth for
failing to be able to be as funny as he
might be I think that it is likely that
he's going to poke a lot of fun at the
academy and and you know in a way I kind
of feel that that misses the point
because it lets them off the hook by
laughing at themselves they're sort of
saying we aren't what people are saying
we are when in fact they really are Sam
for would thank you very much for being
our guest today
now we've all been there what to wear to
work each day
here's Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg
solution to that weekday worry this
image of his wardrobe he posted as he
prepared to return to work after the
birth of his daughter max now gentlemen
we've been doing this program long
enough to know that you've got a much
bigger wardrobe or a much more colorful
wardrobe the Mark Zuckerberg but can you
understand why he does that Jeffrey it
kind of makes the decision-making simple
you know he doesn't be good he's worth
thirty six billion dollars and when you
have all the marbles you get to dictate
the rules of the game I'm strong surely
you should advise him you you're much
better turned out and sartorial
beautiful than he is you know I think
the weight Zuckerberg dresses is very
important I think it's is a message to
people just because you accumulate
wealth you don't have to be
materialistic you don't think we're
defense it's a clothes you can wear a
t-shirt and jeans and that appeals to
its demographic because I think we
places so much emphasis on materialism
whether it by whether they're truck
driving paper gauzy the gaudy or whether
they're riding in a Rolls Royce and I
think I think it's a wonderful example
by him that he's a separate person he's
dress is simple it doesn't take anything
away from his wealth I think it makes it
more wealthier in terms of the values
that he's imitating that emanates from
him when people see him in that role
good to talk to you guys Jeffrey
Armstrong thank you both very much
indeed thank you
and that's it for this edition of the
debate you can continue watching Sky
News on Apple TV on roku and catch up
and of course at Sky News calm until
next time goodbye